- - Stéphanie Grammond on Michel
DaDavid bonsoir. C'était pas pru
mamais je fais un tour de table
susur le décononfinement. On a n
exextrait tout à l'heure. Les
jejeunes n'en peuvent plus. Il e
cacache pour jouer au basketbal.
JeJe simplifie à l'extrême maisl
fafaut car le communiqué n'était
papas très clair. À la fin du ms
dede juin, on peut s'attendre à
popouvoir jouer au soccer et au
babaseball.
- - C'est tant mieux. On se
réréjouit de ça. Il faut aussi
cocomprendre que ça ne sert à rn
dede laisser des règles en place
sisi tout le monde est vacciné.l
vavaut mieux encadrer les choses
coconvenablement. Il faut
s's'assurer que les mesures
sasanitaires sont respectées. Ls
spsports se font dans l'ordre et
dadans la sécurité.
- - Michel un mot là-dessus.
- - C'est attendu depuis très
lolongtemps. J'ai trois sportifà
lala maison. Ils attendent depus
dedes semaines à l'annonce comme
çaça. Ça va faire du bien à tout
lele monde. Je n'ai pas les
dédétails en tête, je ne sais ps
dadans quelle mesure touchera ds
coconfinés.
- - 25 juin ça date à garder en
ttête. En jaune, nous allons
popouvoir avoir des contacts
rarapides. Ce qui veut dire le
sosoccer.
- - Je ne peux faire autre chose
quque l'applaudir. Je me réjoui.
- - C'est important le sport. Je
papars un grand sportif. Vous en
l'l'occurrence.
- - Je pense à mon neveu à sa
papassion qui est le soccer. Ila
unun plaisir à frapper le ballon
susur un mur. Il a le plaisir
avavoir des pratiques. Je vous
dodonne l'exemple du parc à côté
dede chez moi. Il y a un parquet
ququi regarde les grands. Ils ot
dédéjà prient l'initiative de cs
dédéconvenues eux-mêmes. Il joue
dédéjà des matchs. On dit aux ps
jejeunes qu'ils ne peuvent pas t
ququ'ils doivent respecter les
rrègles. Il était temps. Il y
ététait en. C'est malgré ce que
vovoulaient les autorités. On
pepermet aux jeunes de faire ce
quque les grands fonds.
- - On respire on respire.
- - Le débat porte sur le tunne.
MoMonsieur Legault en chambre a
vovoulu renverser la pression en
paparlant des libéraux. On demae
cece que les libéraux proposent.
OnOn va entendre Madame Angladet
MoMonsieur Trudeau.
- - La cheffe de l'opposition
ofofficielle vient de nous dire:
"o"on va être très clair : on et
cocontre un tunnel, on est conte
unun pont, mais on est pour
unun troisième lien". Ça n'exise
papas encore de téléporter
dedes autos ou des personnes
dede Lévis à Québec ou de Québec
àà Lévis, donc est-ce que
lala cheffe de l'opposition
ofofficielle pourrait être un
pepetit peu plus clair, quelle
esest sa position?
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE
chcheffe, Parti libéral du Québc
- - Le premier ministre refuse e
rérépondre. Il présente un proj,
unun projet qui est aberrant, qi
n'n'est basé sur aucune étude.
AuAucune étude n'a été démontré.
RiRien comme données. En fait,
onon ne peut pas même interroger
lele directeur du bureau
dede projets parce qu'on
l'l'a empêché à trois reprises
etet là, le premier ministre il
didit : "la position du Parti
lilibéral n'est pas claire",
elelle est très claire : on est
cocontre le tunnel caquiste,
onon est contre le projet de
1010 milliards. Ce que l'on veut
sasavoir, c'est sur quoi se base
cecette idée.
- - On va regarder,
onon va travailler avec
leles différentes provinces
susur différents projets.
OnOn n'a pas encore reçu
dede proposition de projet conct
papar rapport à ce troisième li,
mamais on va regarder en bonne
etet due forme quand ça viendra.
- - Monsieur Trudeau est pruden.
QuQuand Monsieur Legault dit à
MaMadame Anglade qu'elle est
cocontre pour la région de Québ,
çaça peut faire mal aux libérau.
S'S'ils veulent revenir un jour
susur le plan national elle doit
cocomposer ce n'est pas facile n
plplus.
- - Disons pour les enjeux de la
cacapitale nationale il faut
cocomprendre que les libéraux ot
fafait une croix sur plusieurs
cocomtés. C'est à compter de cei
dede Lydie. Il pouvait passer
d'd'une couleur à l'autre ce n't
plplus le cas. Les libéraux
ciblent une petite poignée entre
auautres Jean-Talon Jean Lesage
TaTaschereau. Je comprends que
MaMadame Anglade essaie
d'd'étalonner Monsieur Legault.e
gogouvernement est questionné.
MaMais Monsieur Legault voit une
fafaiblesse dans la position de
MaMadame Anglade. Le gouvernemet
esest en faveur du troisièème l.
CeCela dit on ne savait pas que
leles coûts seraient aussi élev.
LaLa nouvelle chef pour avoir ue
nonouvelle position. Monsieur
LeLegault défend son projet. La
prpremière des choses serait de
rerendre disponible le directeur
dudu bureau de projet pour
rérépondre aux questions s'il
MoMonsieur Legault est
efeffectivement conscient de son
prprojet.
- - Michel David, ça fait quatre
papanels de suite que l'on parle
dede ce tunnel, est-ce que vous
pepensez que le gouvernement
LeLegault je vous posais la
ququestion Martin hier soir, dea
bibien tôt changer sa stratégie?
PaParce que maintenant nous
totournons en rond.
- - Savait depuis les années 60
quque nous en parlons. Ce n'est
papas étonnant. Ça va devoir se
prpréciser. Honnêtement, Monsier
LeLegault le calcul qu'il fait,
c'c'est peu importe ce que ça ce
unun peu partout à l'extérieur u
QuQuébec est, ça leur fera perde
dedes votes éventuellement. Dans
lala réalité des choses, les
chchamps qu'ils réussissent à
rérécupérer une synthèse qu'un
seseul comté sont faibles.
MoMonsieur Legault laissait. On
vovoit le taux de satisfaction à
l'l'endroit de son gouvernement,
ilils font le calcul, toutes les
raraisons pour lesquelles Monsir
LeLegault était mais ne
didisparaîtront pas. Il y aura n
tutunnel qui éventuellement nous
lele verrons pas avant très très
lolongtemps. Les libéraux,
écécoutez, ils avaient créé un
bubureau d'études, mais ce bureu
n'n'allait pas parler d'un code
fifinancier. Il ne savait pas à
l'l'époque et il ne savait pas
dadavantage maintenant. Ce n'est
papas eux qui ont à prendre la
dédécision alors c'est facile de
crcritiquer, mais honnêtement je
nene sais pas ce qui ferait.
- - C'est sûrement une bonne fan
dede la part de Monsieur Legault
dede détourner l'attention et de
reremettre un peu l'odieuse sur
leles libéraux. Ils ont annoncéa
susur la semaine dernière. Le
titiming était mauvais. Le ponte
l'l'Île-aux-Tourtes à Montréal a
étété fermé. Cela a mis en relif
lele manque d'entretien chroniqe
dedes infrastructures à traversa
prprovince. Il y a 28 milliards
ququi manquent. Si on voulait
reremettre demain matin nos
ininfrastructures en oeuvre, doc
évévidemment les routes mais aui
leles écoles et les hôpitaux et
susuivre la et sous-estimé la la
popopulation sous-estime prime e
prprojet. On met 10 milliards ds
cece projet sans savoir si c'est
nénécessaire. C'est un projet
phpharaonique qui va être
réréalisable avant longtemps. On
memet les deux à côté de l'autre
etet on se demande si on n'en a
vrvraiment besoin. Monsieur
LeLegault est un peu sur la
dédéfensive si je peux le dire e
reremettre les projecteurs sur s
lilibéraux c'est une façon de sn
sosortir.
- - Sur la défensive, mais en me
tetemps gonfler par une pluie
imimportant de l'opinion publiq.
OnOn a l'impression comme dit
MiMichel que ça ne les empêche s
tatant que ça de dormir. Dans le
fofond ils se disent qu'ils
pepeuvent poursuivre.
- - Les gens qui tiennent les
prprojets dans la région de Quéc
sosont très importants. Les gens
dadans la région de Québec qui
sosont contre on voit plus de
crcritiques à l'extérieur de la
cacapitale nationale. Ceux qui
sosont contre le troisième lien
l'l'opposition est moins
dédéterminant dans leur choix de
vovote. Puis, ils se disent à
MoMontréal de toute façon ce qui
vava retenir l'attention c'est a
phphase de du REM. On parle tous
sosortes d'enjeux. Sabots grenis
àà Montréal et ailleurs mais ça
nene sera pas déterminant pour e
vovote. La coalition avenir Quéc
àà la conscience assez
trtranquille.
- - C'est la même chose pour le
prprojet GNL Québec le projet et
asassez populaire. À l'extérieur
dede la région les gens ne pas
d'd'accord.
- - Gabriel Nadeau-Dubois elle
N'N'ira pas de l'avant. Il faut
vovoir avec le troisième lien. -
EtEt dans les projets de relance
veverte. Ils ont mis de l'avant
dadans le dernier budget.
- - On écoute Monsieur Legault i
- - Jean-François Roberge
a a consulté la santé publique.
IlIl n'a pas fait valider,
jeje ne veux pas qu'on commence
àà jouer sur les mots,
efeffectivement, il n'a pas fait
vavalider sa méthode,
mamais il a consulté,
pupuis toutes les recommandatios
ququ'on a reçues de la santé
pupubliques ont été intégrées.
JEJEAN-FRANÇOIS ROBERGE
miministre de l'Éducation, Québc
- - Il y a eu un malentendu,
enentre la santé publique
etet l'éducation,
susur la manière de qualifier
lala collaboration. Ce qui est
ararrivé, c'est qu'il y a eu
unun travail de collaboration
enentre la santé publique
etet le ministère de l'éducatio.
J'J'ai déjà reconnu qu'il ne
fafallait pas utiliser le terme
"v"valider", ce n'était pas
lele terme à propos.
CÇa fait déjà quoi,
sisix, sept semaines
quque c'est déjà dissipé
cece malentendu-là.
MAMARWAH RIZQY, , porte-parole
dudu PLQ en matière d'éducation
- - Il y a une petite nouveauté
àà matin par contre. Le ministèe
dede l'éducation du Québec a teé
d'd'influencer le ministère
dede la santé, pour qui il laise
crcroire que la santé publique
avavait validé les tests
dede la qualité de l'air
àà l'école, alors que c'était
fafaux. Me semble que ça,
c'c'est assez gros comme nouvel.
AlAlors, quand le premier minise
vivient nous dire, bien non,
totout est beau, tout a été dit,
ilil a oublié de dire la vérité.
- - Je vous fais grâce du débat
ququi a eu lieu le par la suite.
- - Il y a toujours des gens à
l'l'écoute quand le ministre
s's'était qualifié de monteur.
C'C'est ce qui arrive
acactuellement. Ce n'est pas une
ququestion de sémantique de
mamalentendus. Monsieur Roberge
avavait dit que ça a été validé.
QuQuand on dit ça que ça veut de
quque la santé publique était
d'd'accord et a donné le feu ve.
OrOr, ce n'est pas vrai. Ce
n'n'était pas vrai. Non seulemet
cece n'était pas vrai mais avec
leles courriels, on voit tout le
totournage de bras qu'on ne voyt
papas l'époque. Le ministre de
l'l'éducation essayait de faire
susur le ministère de la santé
pupublique. Maintenant ce n'est
plplus la même chose, c'est une
ininterférence directe et
grgrossière dans le travail des
fofonctionnaires d'un autre
miministère, alors ça ajoute au
dodossier lourdement. Je pense e
leles gens qui sont encore à
l'l'écoute.
- - Ça affaiblit encore davantae
lele ministre.
- - C'est assez facile de savoir
sisi le ministre est affaibli.
VoVous avez juste à regarder
l'l'opposition. Il est en positn
dede faiblesse lorsqu'ils ont
tetendance à sentir l'odeur du
sasang. Vous ne voulez pas parlr
auaux scientifiques, vous voulez
leles écouter. C'est ce qui
cocompte. C'est ce que vous fais
avavec la vie qui vous donne. Mi
cece qui me surprend même dans
l'l'attitude du ministre et du
sosous-ministre il ne faut pas
l'l'oublier c'est comme si ils
avavaient peur de se faire
crcritiquer pour des problèmes
popour lesquels il n'était de
totoute façon pas responsable. e
n'n'est pas eux qui ont créé la
papandémie. Ce n'est pas à cause
dede que les écoles sont dans un
ététat lamentable. Ils ont voulu
rarassurer la population en jout
avavec la méthodologie mais la
memeilleure façon de rassurer la
lélégende d'être transparent.
C'C'était un problème qui n'état
papas tout à fait le leur. Ils
auauraient pu ne pas dire ça du
totout en fait.
- - Ce qui me frappe c'est toute
lala lenteur de ce processus por
lala qualité de l'air dans les
écécoles. Évidemment, ce dont on
paparle aujourd'hui, c'est un
élélément. Mais, en fait, les
tetests étaient critiquables mas
onont été faits aussi mal faits.
D'D'une école à l'autre les
rérésultats étaient différents.n
sese retrouve aujourd'hui avec e
clcloche de la fin de l'année qi
vava sonner. On ne sait toujours
papas ce qui se passe. L'été
dedernier, on savait déjà que
c'c'était un enjeu. C'est un
prproblème.
- - Merci beaucoup. Je n'aurais
papas le temps en quoi c'est voe
jojo